i don't know if you what your latest is
on bitcoin i'm just looking at the price
right now it's just under 19 000.
bitcoin i i'm
i'm concerned uh i mean i don't want to
scare i know this is a bitcoin friendly
program i myself am a bitcoiner um but
i'm definitely concerned and here's why
you know we made a call going back to
april that we thought the support
support for bitcoin where you would back
the truck up and buy it was 19 000. uh i
am shocked
that we are here so fast i am absolutely
shocked that we have gotten down here so
quickly and that tells me that if
nineteen thousand doesn't hold
i don't know pick up pick a round number
fifteen thousand ten thousand i don't
know there's no support when what you
break nineteen does at least not in
terms of our analysis and so you know we
talk about this liquidity cycle downturn
let's not forget that we're only doing
about half the total amount of
quantitative tightening that the fed
intends to initiate you know in over the
course of the medium term so by
september we're going to double the pace
of quantitative tightening from draining
45 billion uh 45 billion of liquidity
out of the market for lack of a better
phrase um to 95 billion um that's that's
as fast that's like as fast as a fed has
ever drained liquidity from the market
by a double and so my point of bringing
up is that when you factor that in you
factor in the over capitalization of the
treasury as a function of you know the
and the t bill shortens as a result of
that and ultimately the the rapidly
rising uptake in the fed's reverse
rebuild facility balance all these
dynamics are sort of combining to drain
massive amounts of liquidity from
financial markets and so if you do the
math on our analysis you know we get to
about you know basically you know just i
have a trillion dollars of liquidity is
going to get drained from financial
markets between now and you're in if the
fed stays on this course and if the
dynamics with the reverse report
facility don't materially change if that
happens
fair value on the s p 500 is 2900 so
guess where bitcoin is going to be on a
correlation weighted basis if the market
declines uh significantly from here
i'm just looking
right now um
you said a trillion
it's 915 billion to be exact so that's
okay okay i know i'm i i guess like the
quick following question too like when
you talk about the liquidity cycle
downturn you said the top of this
program we're in the fifth or sixth
inning um does it accelerate over time
does it get like
as you go through that cycle like how
does that kind of how does that play out
is it like a smooth thing or does it
just like smile and get worse and worse
as you get further in the cycle
i'd love for it to be smooth but the
reality is you know we get to 4 30 in
the morning every day because it's not
smooth it's non-linear
markets are you know they're dynamic
ecosystems and so the reality is you
know one acceleration and one factor can
lead to a deceleration another factor
and vice versa one thing we know we're
going to get is we're very likely to get
a a a reduction in the size of rate
increases particularly after we get past
this july 27th fomc meeting i'm not so
sure we're going to get another 75
basement rate hike i mean maybe it's 75
but i think you know by the time we get
there it could be 50 if we get a couple
of decent inflation prints we get june
cpi on the 13th maybe we get some
decline significant decline in crude oil
into the summertime potentially i don't
know i'm not making that call
that could cause the fed to go to 50 in
july 27 but the reality is you know
we're not going to stick at 75 75 75
that's unlikely um so you know we're
going to see a slowdown in the pace of
rate hikes but we're at the same time
we're going to get an acceleration in
the the quantitative tightening program
so you know on that generally speaking
quantitative tightening has a more of a
near-term sort of coincident impact on
asset markets qe and qt than interest
rate hikes and interest rates